the story behind the greenwich episode
began far away from london
the last two decades of the 19th century
saw a series of anarchist-inspired
terrorist attacks hit countries across
europe
in november 1884 an international
diplomatic conference was held at
washington d.c that selected greenwich's
world famous observatory as the prime
minister of the world the origin for all
time and space measurement the place
whose time would set the beat for the
whole world
now the reason given for selecting
greenwich was a practical one
something like 75 of the world's ships
by tonnage used charts based on the
greenwich meridian and that was because
the london chart makers were the most
prolific
so selecting the greenwich meridian was
seen to inconvenience the fewest people
the only major country attending the
washington conference to abstain from
the vote for greenwich
was france
and the conference opened what was to
become a running saw in the psyche of
the french nation
at the time the french delegate lobbied
hard for the decision to be reversed
and later france just refused to
recognize the results of the conference
french commentators saw it as an act of
hostile imperialism on the part of
britain and i think it's easy to see
their point although you might well
disagree
in january 1885 just a few weeks after
the washington meridian conference shone
a spotlight on his observatory the
astronomer royale at greenwich william
christie wrote to his government worried
about possible bomb attacks on his
buildings just three weeks later an
anonymous letter was received by the
authorities containing threats to blow
up saint paul's cathedral prompting them
to close off the cathedral's clock and
bell chamber fearing a symbolic act of
violence against the clock and it
remained closed for years
by late 1893 anarchist terrorists were
particularly active in france
culminating in a bombing of the chamber
of deputies in paris that december
then on the evening of monday the 12th
of february 1894
an anarchist threw a bomb into the
crowded cafe of the grand hotel terminu
in the rue salazar in paris next to a
major railway station 20 people were
injured in the explosion and one of them
later died from his injuries
three days later
in england an explosion was heard across
greenwich the royal observatory gate
porter and two of its astronomers raced
out towards a path where they could see
smoke rising
there they found the park keeper and two
pupils from a local boys school who'd
been first on the scene
first sight they didn't appear to be
much wrong a young man later identified
as marshall bordan was kneeling on the
path by railings perfectly still
with his head bowed
but then he fell forward
he was taken to a nearby hospital where
he died 25 minutes later
marshall bourdain was a french anarchist
and he knew emil henry the person who'd
attacked the grand hotel in paris three
days earlier very well marshall burdon
had been carrying a bomb to the
greenwich observatory he was only meters
away from his target with the bomb
primed in his hand when he tripped and
fell forward onto it
it exploded and killed him
just around the corner from where he was
fatally injured are the gates that lead
into the observatory's large courtyard
and there beside the gates to this day
is the large round white dial of the
observatory's electric public clock
set in a wall at head height behind
glass
it's an official clock that had
displayed britain's standardized
authoritative greenwich meantime
since the mid 19th century in 1884 when
the western world's government
representatives had decided that all the
people of earth should march to the beat
of one clock
it was this clock it was the powerful
living embodiment of all that anarchists
like buddha despised authority and
hierarchy
this was to have been the end of
marshall bourdain's journey that day in
1894 if he hadn't tripped and bungled
the plan
marshall bordan had been moments away
from bombing greenwich meantime itself
emile henry the paris bomber said this
at his trial
he said you have hanged us in chicago
decapitated us in germany garrodded us
in her wreth
shot us in barcelona guillotined us in
monbriza and in paris but what you can
never destroy is anarchy
its roots are too deep
born in a poisonous society which is
falling apart
anarchism he said
is a violent reaction against the
established order
and ori's choice of words there is
telling established order means
political institutions and structures
but it also refers to the work of
measurement scientists like the
astronomers working at time finding
observatories
their work is in establishing order
then as now it was impossible to
separate science from society impossible
to see the work of any institution like
an observatory as purely scientific
rather than bound up in politics and
wider culture
the greenwich observatory clock is an
imperial clock
and clocks and empires go hand in hand